we've seen is less tolerance and more
violence
and i know for a fact
i've seen that in my courtroom and it
seems like the threats have escalated
against the judges
escalating threats against local judges
in their own courtrooms and it's a story
right out of the wild west the nye
county board of commissioners voting to
allow guns in most areas of their
courthouses but as the 8 news now
i-team's david charn shows us the judges
say this decision is just asking for
trouble
over here
keep them right here
judge kim walker's gun is right by her
side when she's presiding over her
courtroom i'm certain it's an incident
waiting to happen it's not if it happens
it's when it happens this is your
purpose
her district court offices are in an
i-county building today court is not in
session but on days it is people filing
into her courtroom go through a metal
detector her bailiff sets up at the door
there's no security at the main entrance
the county controls the building and
commissioners say they control the halls
i
think that probably the greatest threat
or risk
for an incident is in the hallways or in
the parking lot the four judges working
out of this building enter through the
same doors as everyone else they park
out front too we have a joke here so my
staff laughs and says judge we're so
glad they improved the lighting because
now when they shoot from the dark
parking lot they'll be sure they get you
and not us this door is not locked the
back door right next to judge wonker's
courtroom the way prisoners come through
from jail doesn't lock commissioner
jabor you brought this item up until
this meeting in december just a piece of
paper stopped a person from bringing a
gun into this building in addition to
district and justice courts they have
windows that can be shot out the
district attorney and the clerk are also
here
12 years ago after several shootings at
courthouses including this one at the
federal building in las vegas judge
robert lane wrote this order forbidding
firearms instead county employees could
apply to carry a concealed weapon in the
building
as this email from this fall shows
commissioner bruce jabor's application
was denied judge lane and judge
wonker have serious concerns for their
safety
but obviously no concern for the safety
of others including myself
the commissioners unanimously voting to
remove that order allowing guns in the
building the court has no such authority
to control the right of access to these
governmental offices simply because
they're in the same building as the
court technically if
based on the decision you could walk in
with an ar-15 rifle i want you to raise
your hand if you own a gun
several several seven
three of the judges working here lane
wonker and justice court judge kent
jasperson say this isn't about the
second amendment and the county has
rules on the books about guns in the
workplace the collective bargaining
agreement with the nye county employee
association says the county shall have
the right to discharge or discipline any
employee for a list of reasons including
carrying or possessing firearms or
weapons while on the job you don't need
to have a gun here to resolve an issue
the only thing a gun is going to do is
aggravate the situation kind of an old
west cowboy kind of thing we'll have to
shoot out
security measures like this 90 thousand
dollar scanner sit in storage the judges
say the county won't pay to staff it and
just because we're rural doesn't mean
incidents aren't going to happen the
i-team reviewed thousands of calls for
service at the complex over the past
decade while the list includes the
sheriff's office and the jail records
show deputies have responded to the
courts for everything from assaults to
domestic disputes to threats walker says
last summer a man threatened to come to
the courthouse before he could he got in
a shootout with deputies so i ran from
office to office pounding on the doors
telling people to get away from the
windows active shooter on their way we
reached out to commissioner jabor and
the board chair to hear their side of
the story they either declined or did
not respond i'm david charns live local
now